[Music]
all right we're going to watch a video
of an escalating situation and you know
it's it's about 3 minutes long what we
might skip to some you know and do some
fast boting but at the same time I'm
pretty sure we're going to have some
live commenting so it's going to you
know all right
here
we pause Volume Up full
size and here we go
Prof oh what's going on is this full
brightness what did isue for a defective
equipment it's $80 you have till to take
care of this uh get you to sign there
with the x is so you don't even give a
warning for this you've been driving
around for 6 months like that I'm
truthful well I'm not going to give you
a warning for something you've been
driving for 6 months that I don't want
to sign it cuz I don't want to do $8
draw draw and shoot no because
to pay $8 for
something and I can fix it that's all
you want why you're under
arrest Step Up Le pepper arrested for
not signing oh I've seen this I think be
fair with me and I'll be fair with you
sho the F the rules Dum ho I have a
gun step out
well cuz that escalates it right signing
is not a admission it's just I'm going
to appear in court do not shut up and
give me that and I'll sign it step out
we're beyond that step out yeah we
are now she's committed a crime she's
been committing crimes C [__]
man super cop yeah get out of the car
get out of the car blue lives matter
[__] you're about to find
out get out of the car where is this at
Oklahoma uh I don't know
America get out of the
car put your hands behind your know
[Music]
your what did she say leave me alone I
mean oh hell
yes put hands behind your back Allah the
almighty is great he [__] put your
hands behind your back good enough
that's I think Mike pretty much summed
it up the truth be told my wife and I
have seen that video numerous times yeah
you guys watch this [__] my wife is full
of hate and and I and I love that woman
more than
any love to see her hate the [__] out of
a situation yeah yeah yeah how does did
she think she was signing to admit guilt
cuz all you do is sign and say all right
well we'll see you at court or whatever
right well I mean it's it's a ticket
right cuz I didn't hear what she was say
so it's a it's a fix it ticket
apparently she's been driving around
with some sort of broken whatever for
like six like a headlight she did all
that for a headlight so it cost 80
buckss [__] dumb dude 80 bucks and
now look where you are yeah you know how
fixing tickets works you know you got to
go fix it and you got to go to the
police station you got to prove to the
officer that that you fixed it you pay
the fine that's it it's definitely
really [__] annoying but it's way
better than a be ticket you know or
[__] invading the police and getting
shot by a taser I swear to God a bunch
of these interactions it's like the
actual crime is like nothing but it
escalates the presence of the officer is
really designed to test if you're
civilized or not like civility means you
understand there's a rule structure that
you don't directly negotiate on the spot
cuz she was like you be fair with me and
I be fair with you [__] we're not
constructing the [__] Magna cartter
right now
L down a long time ago you live in a you
society's a big team [__] you on a team
and there's hundreds of millions of the
rest of us pull your weight pull your
[__] weight shut the [__] up and pay
your [__] ticket and if you don't do
that [__] drop that
[Laughter]
[__] there's so many people that just
don't know protocol well there is I
think there's this thing where like
there's just so many people like they
need to like they're they're arguing
with a family member so they feel like
they need to find the solution right
here and there but then Society always
has this preset rules so you just go
through the motions then you have your
lawyer at court and that's where you
actually present your case and do
everything argu is called Court yeah but
why are they trying to settle it right
now like that's judge and jury with the
police officer they trying to
rationalize
unrationed me they weren't taught like
the basics or they didn't learn at
school honestly I think a lot of people
is just like they're just dumb they're
getting their their emotions just carry
them the [__] Al so they're just like
mad and then they're just impulsive it
was clearly like an authority thing
she's like obviously like a matriarch
type of [__] and she's like an old
southern Auntie or whatever so she
always gets like a lot of respect you
know she's always on her terms nobody's
going to [__] heart take down a
90-year-old [__] like that's true but
he did it but like the law [__] the
reason the law is great is cuz in
America statistically on average it it
really doesn't discriminate all that
much you're doing some Dad they don't
give a [__] what your shaped
like that's the best part you're all
getting shot 100% people think like all
this discrimination I'm sure there's
elements of that etc etc but like
something warms my heart about seeing an
old ass white Karen like a Karen's
grandma getting heart cuz you know you
could start to see like videos you're
like man like the cops really seem to
come after some of the races that was
definitely true historically but
nowadays it's less true you want
evidence here's [__] Karen getting
her [__] pushed in many watch that video
you're like all right all right there's
some justice in how many times did this
act work on another cop y like cuz
there's like local cops where like they
know you and they're like all right
Susie just make sure you get it fixed be
on your way that guy didn't know [__]
[__] except pulling my Taser on some
dumb white [__] today am I right fell
she was white yeah [__] she got the car
and drove away that's a big deal that is
so charges titlan is crazy she rolled
the window up and then when she knew she
went too far she's like rolling the
window back down a little bit okay give
it to me out sign yes is that crazy
she's like having a negotiation but I
love that how it was like we're beyond
that now we're beyond thatz the only
reason why she went there is like you
said it's probably worked in the past
for her she done it over and now it's
caught up it's weird when people try to
I think a lot of people I've seen a lot
of [__] cops shows type of [__] body
camp videos people seem to want to
maintain some semblance of control that
they have in a situation they're like I
still got to like like you'll AR they'll
arrest people and put them in the
[__] back and there's like videos 20
minutes long of a cop just driving not
saying [__] and the person's digging
into them the whole time like you're a
[__] you your wife is ugly she doesn't
even [__] you anymore but but like they
can't charge you with anything cuz
that's not a crime to say anything like
that but at that you're definitely
escalate for sure and also digging a
hole of like cops have choices they they
can be nice or they can be like all
right you get the whole full way to the
law if you're telling a guy he's
impotent and [__] like
that exactly the best way to get the I
know right but it's like but the thing
they need most it seems like is to be
like no I'm still the [__] man I'm
going in on my terms and they'll be like
we get to the jail you better treat me
with respect you're like what the
[__] like like he said on that [__] have
no leverage here no leverage and they
don't their Leverage is their ego
they're like I can't be made cuz the
ultimate thing about the law is it
doesn't matter what the who the [__] you
are in the modern
world you dip your [__] head down
with the [__] law and you [__] do
what you're supposed to cuz that's how
we maintain order and civility like your
boy was flying to Canada a few weeks
back and it turns out that see you see
CBD gummies are legal in America and
they're legal in Canada too transporting
them on an airplane even if it's four
[__] gummies in my goddamn vitamin
compartment for the [__] week is like
an offense [__] pulled out of the
[__] crowd [__] they knew that [__]
lucky guess they look like Putin or
whatever but I dude but they got me in
the [__] back room and they went
through everything and they're like
what's this what's this what's that I
had a lot of funny explaining to do with
various potions and powders but I'm sure
was all eagle and they're like this what
is this gummy and I was like CBD cuz I
like generally don't lie to the
authorities and they're like the guy's
like we can actually have you arrested
for that and I like I'm saying like do
well for myself I'm not scared often but
like instantly I was like and the only
thing I said was like yeah I understand
yeah but if you were subit to Authority
what am I going to do what am I going to
do there's eight [__] it's Canadians
it's not that scary you could have taken
them yeah right but there's like there's
like you know I did like the quick spot
check of like he's close enough for me
to get him and then there's like eight
other highly trained armed officers it's
going to be a rain of bullets I I think
I think that thought I was like I was
like no NOP Israel shut the [__] up and
just take the [__] and they were super
[__] reasonable they're like sorry
just throw them away and you're good and
I'm
like I was getting ready to go to jail
in Montreal which is hard as
[__] I walk into that jail and be like
who the [__] thinks they're in charge
sit the [__] down everyone's just
sitting like that like sorry all right
sorry a Big Moose comes out I am I'm
like oh hell yes same time but yeah no
like the law is the law man that sh and
they have guns do people forget that
cops have guns and have a legal ability
to use them [__] I think people do
forget I think people don't know how the
law operates and they just see a person
that's bullying them another human yeah
they just go you're being a bully and
they're taking it personal I'm going to
stand up to you yeah and I'm not going
to let you push me around cuz it's a
pride thing of now I need my respect I
think that's what I see a lot of the
times because what's also crazy is
people see that even at a Starbucks like
I'll see someone like yelling at like a
19-year-old right cuz I don't think they
see a 19-year-old they just person they
see yeah they see like a a server or a
Starbucks representative full of
corporate Authority yeah and I'm like
they don't have the call or they don't
have the authority to make the call you
want you can stay calm and just go hey
can I speak to your manager please and
have another calm conversation and get
the whole thing resolved instead they
have to let out all their emotions and
dump it on this poor 19-year-old that's
working here part-time probably doesn't
want to work here probably needs to
study for their finals or whatever and
people just don't see that side of yeah
well emotional intelligence yeah never
had any of that I don't know what that
is either I'm a woman here it's
overrated nonsense women are highly
emotionally intell nonsense nonsense
yeah stuff like yelling at customer
service representatives and [__] like
that too it really wigs me out when
people do it uh because it's like that's
another human being that just went to
work that day and they're God damn
they're trying their [__] best it's
also highly ineffective like if you yell
at someone the probability of really
trying to help you it scales down quite
quickly sometimes it's therapeutic to
just [__] you just yell at sometimes
you just need to get off your chest
check it out Delta Airlines [__] all of
you and they're like all right get off
the plane you're like ah
time you're when you're saying the same
story to the customer service it does
get to you though cuz I I don't really
do that until like the fifth time I'm
like why do I got to re say the same
thing again to another [__] rep just
give me a manager yeah and I don't like
saying give me a manager but I'm like
give me someone that has Authority
competence though too because there are
a lot of people to flip the coin a lot
of people who will work jobs who are
completely incompetent in that job yeah
you're right and that's tough that's
tough cuz you're just sitting there like
I just need let me just go through the
five incompetent people get somebody
remotely able to do this and then I hang
up and I go I wish I was richer I wish I
was listen you know Jared I have done
quite well for ourselves we're on
customer service line just like you
there's nobody up above I'm like can I
speak to a manager like I am the manager
[__] [__] son of a [__] and I'm
like Jesus Christ the [__] did I call
Chase Bank it was my
wife
for